opposers it is awards season and I'm not
talking about that elitist tux rental
pyramid scam the Emmy Awards who've
ignored this show for years just because
it wasn't on television fYI we've been
airing our radio show mouths justice on
the dark web for decades and their
awards are more more prestigious also
they're stuffed with opioids and Tiger
horn I'm also not talking about Saturday
night's DC wank fest the White House
Correspondents Dinner where comedian
Michelle wolf violated traditions and
norms by telling jokes I don't even know
what she was thinking
you don't speak truth to power that's
bullying you tell power how good it
looks and then you move on now I'm
talking about the only award season that
matters Nobel Peace Prize season it must
be time to give it out because
everyone's talking about the clear
favorite
Donald diplomacy Trump South Korea's
president says that President Trump
should win the Nobel Peace Prize for his
efforts to end the standoff President
Trump if he can lead us to ending the
Korean War after 70 years deserves the
Nobel Peace Prize
[Applause]
no bail no bail listen that craw
give me no bail that's actually how the
winner is chosen by a applause-o-meter
it's a little-known fact Henry Kissinger
won his when a crowd went apeshit at a
Pistons game now the Nobel Committee
needs to act now they should have
already given trump the Nobel for his
response to Charlottesville when he had
the vision to see good people on both
sides I mean that's peace through
tolerance and Trump can tolerate
you wouldn't believe now if you've been
living in a cave for the last year which
I recommend you do to avoid their oxygen
you might be wondering how Trump earned
this latest Peace Prize watch and bring
an olive branch to the North Korean
crisis Kim Jong moon of North Korea who
is obviously a madman Rocket Man is on a
suicide mission for himself
north Korea has just launched another
missile does this guy have anything
better to do with his life why would Kim
Jung on insult me by calling me old when
I would never call him short and fat
whoo now that's a tactic the Kennedy
School of Government would call choke on
this tweet biatch
look it up it's called insult diplomacy
and it has always worked like when
Reagan told Gorbachev your mama's so fat
tear down this wall like it's working
again
look at these two lovebirds North Korea
and South Korea coming together again
and who made it happen
king of the clap back Andrew Dice Trump
and no one is modest like the dice man
what do you think President Trump had to
do with it I'll tell you what like how
about everything yeah throw PES
everything to do with everything
Korean peace talks n sync's Hollywood
star America's victory in Vietnam
everything bottom line this is how you
change the world insults burns mockery
those are in the diplomats toolbox and
whoever masters that gets that big fat
Swedish nickel oh my god I just realized
it
someone is coming for Donald's Peace
Prize my fence is what happens when
Anderson Cooper isn't gay
Fox News is here so you know what that
means ladies cover your drinks change
I'd say to Michelle wolf hallelujah girl
you should be the one getting the Nobel
Peace Prize me
[Music]
no no stop acting like a president you
want to steal the Donalds Peace Prize
this is war the fight continues
[Music]